the air is a very salty player and he's
a player who likes to think from the
start so in in that thing were similar
would like to think and understand so to
make moves that would feel are the best
moves in a position well it's a big
challenge of course he is one of the
best players in the world but also I
think in this type of chess is also the
giant I would say because he was playing
I don't remember it like 10 years ago
maybe maybe a bit more he was playing
some some matches against I got more he
was playing mains I think and he was
doing quite well I think it will be an
interesting match last time I play the
measure was Karl against a car and he
was too fast for me I remember but back
back in a day I think I was I was
playing much slower I think my bliss has
improved all the time that I've played
against him I think in general his style
[Music]
it's quite good for for this type of
chess because he's a creative player and
yeah should be should be a tough
challenge for me but I hope to to do my
best in a match against the new year I
think the hardest part for me will be
you know getting to trick him into
getting some strange positions because
that's what I like at this level
obviously everyone is an expert here
when it comes to openings but the fact
you take away openings thinking in our
case we will make it really interesting
let's let's see how it goes
you